alors j'ai choisi de vous parler des x
gay qui a un mot japonais
tu as peut paraître un peu étrange mais
ce mot n'existe pas en français c'est un
mot qui désigne à la fois la raison
d'être
ce pourquoi on se lève le matin et la
joie de vivre et c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne lit pas forcément très souvent
en france en attendant c'est à dire d'en
bas il ya le travail d'un côté et puis
les loisirs les choses joyeuses de
l'autre et du coup je trouvais ce
concept vraiment très intéressant parce
que ça permet de mettre en lien vos
talons vos envies et à la fois l'utilité
que ça peut avoir pour la société le
travail avant on l'utilisé surtout pour
subvenir à ses besoins basiques et le
besoin physiologique de manger de dormir
et le besoin de sécurité à avoir un toit
et on avait tendance à s'y limiter à ça
on a tous des talents on est tous joué
pour une ou plusieurs choses parfois ils
sont évidents on a une passion on est un
très bon musicien et là ça va être
peut-être un petit peu plus facile parce
que on sait vers quoi se dirige et et on
peut s'imposer un peu plus face à la une
famille est réfractaire face à des gens
qui vont être un peu pessimiste par
rapport à notre projet mais ce qui est
encore plus difficile c'est quand on a
plein de talent ont différents et qu'on
n'ait pas plus passionné que sa part un
de ses talents mais qu'on est attiré par
des tas de choses qui ne ressemble pas
forcément à des métiers moi mon rôle
c'est de d'aider les gens à se révéler
et à briller c'est quelque chose qu'on a
du mal à faire dans notre pays on aime
bien être modeste
oh non moi tu sais je suis pas très
douée au ce que je fais c'est pas grand
chose et en fait cette attitude là qui
peut paraître
sympathique elle n'est pas bénéfique au
monde parce que si on pas si on apporte
pas notre contribution et si on ne donne
pas ce pourquoi on est doué on apporte
pas ce pourquoi le monde attend qu'on
soit là donc il faut se poser la
question quand vous cherchez votre
orientation
2 pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes fait et
pourquoi êtes vous êtes fait c'est lié à
ce pourquoi vous avez envie de vous
lever le matin
c'est quoi le genre de journée qui vous
donne envie de vous lever et qui vous
rend joyeux est ce que c'est une journée
vous allez être dehors à faire du sport
est ce que c'est une journée où vous
allez voir des copains est ce que c'est
une journée où vous allez lire
tranquille déjà c'est une base qui va
vous permettre de commencer une
réflexion mais attention parce que quand
vous avez des rêves
surtout quand vous êtes très jeune on
peut vous dire non mais c'est très
prétentieux ton histoire tu crois
vraiment que toi tu vas réussir à gagner
ta vie avec des choses qui n'ont pas
l'air sérieuses et vous allez vous
prendre des reproches et beaucoup de
positions donc il va falloir être fort
il faut savoir regarder plus loin on va
vous dire aussi quand vous cherchez
votre orientation
si vous êtes doué dans une matière ben
voilà c'est évident dirigeant vers cette
matière dans laquelle tu es doué et ce
sera merveilleux mais si c'est pas du
tout ce qui vous intéresse
ça sera peut-être pas si merveilleux que
ça parce que vous allez devoir
travailler dur alors que quelqu'un qui
aime ça pour lui ça va être naturel du
coup vous allez fort c'est beaucoup plus
et du coup ça va être beaucoup plus dur
pour vous de réussir alors on est dans
une culture où
il ya l'histoire du mérite il faut
travailler dur
il faut souffrir mais en réalité on peut
être heureux on peut faire les choses
avec facilité et c'est pas forcément
devait donc réfléchissez bien à ce qui
va allumer votre flamme qu'est ce qui
fait que le temps va passer à la vitesse
de l'éclair
qu'est ce qui fait que votre journée va
être magique qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de faire tout le temps et le
problème c'est qu'on a tendance à
surtout limité quand on pense à ça parce
que si on pense aux orientations on
pense travail donc on pense truc sérieux
alors évidemment si on aime papoter avec
des copines barboter dans une piscine
feuilleter des magazines et déchirer les
pages de photos qu'on aime bien un fond
se dit non c'est pas un travail
et pourtant si vous voulez en savoir un
peu plus sur mon parcours j'ai été par
exemple directrice artistique qu'est ce
que c'est à directrice artistique entre
autres parce qu'il ya plein de branches
dans la direction artistique
mais mon travail c'était de déchirer les
photos dans des magazines pour créer ce
qu'on appelle des mouches board qui
donnent l'orientation graphique d'un
shooting donc un mes loisirs qui était
le feuilleter des magazines et collecter
les photos que j'ai mais est devenu mon
travail puis après j'ai changé de
travail
j'ai fait une formation et je suis
devenu watsu thérapiste j'ai donné des
massages dans l'eau moquer mais pas
rabotée et passer des heures dans l'eau
ben voilà j'avais trouvé un métier qui
correspondait à sa est en fait il ya
plein de choses qui peuvent paraître
vraiment pas sérieuse mais qui peuvent
se transformer en métier tout est
possible en fait il faut imaginer des
choses et il ya des tas de meetic vous
connaissez pas qu'ils peuvent
correspondre à ce que vous aimez faire
au quotidien ayant eux aussi
métier qui n'existe pas encore donc rien
ne doit vous arrêter et il ya des gens
qui vont vous dire oui mais qui arrivera
pas parce que bon t'as pas l'air
vraiment fait pour ça par exemple quand
j'ai commencé à vouloir être coach il y
avait un vrai problème c'est que j'étais
pas très à l'aise pour parler en public
quand j'ai passé le bac le bac de
français à l'école et 17 alors alger une
neuf parce que je n'étais pas à l'aise
et pourtant c'était devant une personne
un prof
et donc si jamais je vais donner des
conférences et je vais expliquer aux
gens comment être bien dans leur peau
est heureux on m'aurait dit non mais
c'est pas tu arriveras jamais c'est pas
possible tu étais pas doué pour ça donc
en fait quand on a quelque chose qui est
vraiment fort en soi et qu'on a vraiment
envie de le transmettre
ben on peut tout à fait passer par
dessus ça et les compétences qu'on n'a
pas inné en soit on va les acquérir très
facilement parce qu'on va avoir une
motivation énorme alors que si on se
dirige vers quelque chose qu'on aime pas
trop parce qu'on a l'impression que
c'est sûr mais la motivation elle va pas
être très grande et du coup on va pas
pouvoir évoluer beaucoup la question
aussi à se poser c'est quel genre de vie
vous voulez est ce que vous avez envie
de voyager tout le temps ou au contraire
d'être un peu tranquille à la maison est
ce que vous avez envie d'être proche de
la nature
quelles sont vos valeurs est-ce que ce
qui est important pour vous c'est la
famille ou est ce que c'est les amis ou
est-ce que c'est gagné pour
d'argent avoir un titre docteurs avocats
qu'est ce qui est vraiment très
important pour vous c'est aussi une des
questions essentielles à se poser mais
le plus important c'est de toujours
chercher votre rigueur c'est à dire ce
pourquoi vous êtes faits et le monde
attend ça de vous c'est à dire que vous
pouvez avoir l'impression que ce n'est
pas juste de faire un travail qui vous
amuse et que vous pensez que le travail
c'est sérieux il faut faire quelque
chose de désagréable pour que ce soit
efficace
mais en fait non pas du tout c'est pas
ça que le monde attend de vous au
contraire plus vous allez prendre du
plaisir dans ce que vous faites
plus vous avez donné quelque chose de
positif au monde
c'est aussi simple que ça et voilà